c'est la polémique qui agite le monde
des miss en ce moment le comité miss
france accusée de grossophobie la
semaine dernière on apprenait
qu'amandine biou prétendantes au titre
régional de miss auvergne aurait selon
elle était éliminé du concours à cause
de son poids par téléphone on m'a dit
que j'étais beaucoup trop ronde c'est
clairement de la grossophobie tout ça
parce que je fais une taille 42 c'est
dégueulasse mais ce n'est pas marqué
dans le contrat seule la taille
rédhibitoire des propos qu'aurait tenus
le comité seulement au téléphone pour ne
pas garder de trace écrite
vendredi dernier sur notre plateau la
jeune femme a confirmé ses accusations
en fait on m'a clairement dit abete a
une très jolie mythe est très jolie tête
mais le corps ne passe par un verdict
brutal qu'amandine a du mal à comprendre
quand elle repense à son parcours ce que
j'ai pas dit jusqu'à maintenant et
maintenant je le dis c'est qu'on est
venu me chercher au mois de mars
on m'a envoyé un message sur facebook
pour me dire écoute amandine tu as tout
à fait ta place aujourd'hui la jeune
femme n'attends rien du comité miss
france
et elle ne va pas porter plainte ce
qu'elle veut c'est sensibiliser
l'opinion publique sur la grossophobie
moi j'ai 24 ans je pense que j'ai un
minimum quand même la tête sur les
épaules et j'ai un petit peu de recul
sur les choses
ça aurait été une gamine de 18 ans on
lui dit tu es très belle mais était trop
grosse mais vous vous imaginez les
conséquences dramatiques
la présidente du comité miss france
sylvie tellier a essayé d'éteindre cette
polémique en affirmant qu' évidemment il
n'y avait aucune sélection faite sur le
poids alors selon vous la défonce de
sylvie tellier est elle crédible
c'est alors mais peu excuse ou non est
ce que c'est crédible
1 cette justification après je crois que
c'est vous français kévin il est maniaco
effectivement en pas se mentir ça reste
un concours de beauté aiguiller les
critères non assumé mes lecteurs je vous
aime tous mais je vous ai tous trouvé
très très faux cul sur cette histoire
pourquoi parce qu'il ya un critère qui
est implicite
je ne dis pas que c'est bien je dis que
c'est un fait si tu veux être miss
france vaut mieux faire 1,3436 qu'un 42
ça veut pas dire que l n'est pas sublime
cette phase va bientôt la moyenne des
françaises ne peut pas d'accord de ça
veut dire qu'on ne doit pas miss france
c'est tout parce que c'est comme ça la
mission est très grand moi je suis un
mètre soixante cinq jours avant des
bêtes nous alors que trop de doses dont
l'europe est oui vous êtes là
non il n'est pas clair non à la paix
n'est pas du tout moi j'aurais dit ça
comme je vous le dis là moi je veux bien
mais pourquoi commencer pourquoi il est
donc a commencé à faire des concours
fallait pas le langage est mal engagée
pour faire des concours cette fois on
lui a dit viens faire les concours et
moi je dis ce que j'ai dit à semaine à
moi je pense qu'ils m'ont trouvé super
jolie et on dit bien faire les concours
peut-être qu'ils lui ont dit entre
l'avenue thyssen a bougés à l'aller
maigrir un petit peu pour maintenant
dans un an quand même elle a quand même
dit elle a fait toutes les épreuves il
est arrivé dans la vie à ce qu'on dit et
ce qu'on fait donc madame tellier les
gentils mais je la trouve hyper
hypocrite car je trouve surtout que
c'est à pas trop sur ce sujet non plus
je suis désolé dans les faits il n'y a
aucune miss qui fait plus dans 38 quoi
avec
je suis désolé si vous regardez derrière
vous elle a été forte auparavant ils ont
joué là dessus d'ailleurs je trouve
qu'il s'en sont servis dans faire du
buzz mais ils n'ont pas fait gagner
gagner parce qu'elle était alors joué
sur son histoire tout simplement mais en
soit a dit sachant qu'elle ait reçu l a
dit simplement qu'effectivement elle
était un peu forte
à l'époque enfin estimé d'après les
critères de sélection mais ils peuvent
pas dire ouvertement qu'ils ne veulent
pas une fille cas du 49e ils ne peuvent
pas le dire une fille intelligente et
elle est maligne de répondre cela non
pas ce qu'elle peut pour une info qui va
à la réponse je ne peux pas dire c'est
tout simplement de la discrimination
tourner à paris le dire il écrire c'est
non sinon c'est bien décrit menace aussi
de pas prendre quelqu'un qui est petit
c'est dans les critères la taille et
dans les critères des élections
n'auraient pas de honte à assumer un
concours on dit voilà pour faire ce
concours il faut faire avec 72 faire 1
32e
pointure je fais du 44 bombasse à un
médecin 17 célibataire ce sont des
critères respectable lorsque tu touches
ou au point là tu touches à quelque
chose d extrêmement tabou la femme la
jeune femme qui est venue la semaine
dernière elle ne rentrait pas dans
l'annuaire des standards de mary jolie
comme amandine les standards on peut pas
laisser maxime dire ça ne rentrait pas
dans les standards nous brosser les
faits vous rendez vous l'armée fait de
la discrimination et non c'est pas des
faits on line et ça c'est pas des faits
et c'est un vrai problème de société et
en fait je peux vous dire que le sujet
de la semaine dernière il a posé
d'énormes problèmes au comité miss
france parce qu'ils se sont dit comment
réagir c'est une polémique une vraie sur
la glace aux phobies ils sont pris en
flagrant délit de mensonge il sait
exactement la même chose que dans les
castings de cinéma ou télévision tu as
un profil tu veut se profiler tu vas à
l'engager en tant que tel c'est trop ces
impostures rentrer dans une case
et moi je trouve que je vois qu'il
aurait été plus honnête et dire voilà
effectivement pour fermer de france
voilà on impose des critères même si
wallace regarde si vous mettez le
tableau faut s'armer d'un mètre 70 soit
avoir 18 24 ans faute célibataire tout
ça c'est tout ça c'est n'importe quoi il
faut définir quand tu peux être jolie tu
peux être cool tu peux pas faire mais il
faut redéfinir les canons de la beauté
en fait et cette femme que nous avons
reçu hier elle était très belle bien
dans sa peau c'est quand même
l'essentiel dans une vie maintenant il
faut faire évoluer la société ait
accepté qu'une fille un peu plus forte
un peu plus ronde soit demi pourquoi ce
soit
[Applaudissements]
en fait j'ai envie de dire un peu
excusez-moi si vite et lille mais que
vous n'assumez pas c'est une chose que
vous ne voulez pas être accusé de
discrimination c'est une chose mais
arrêtez de prendre les français pour des
cons s'est désolé en plus cette jeune
fille elle est juste sublime et et
excusez moi c'est un avis personnel que
je donne mais je les trouvais tellement
belle et tellement plus belle que
certaines miss france élue au niveau du
visage sans expression mais c'est parce
que ça ne sais pas mais je sais pas si
les couleurs vous pouvez y dédient vous
pourriez vous montrer vos critères là
parce qu'en un mois je vais vous dire ce
critère là il est particulièrement leurs
records le premier critère est né de
sexe féminin on en discute de ça dont je
vis au moins me france
mais non ce n'est pas seulement
[Applaudissements]
sur les joueurs gênés
les personnes qui veulent changer de
genre à dire ça mais ça c'était un vieux
critères qui donnait lieu d'être
ça mais si moi je veux bien cohabiter
moi j'ai aucun point avec tout ce qui
est tout ce qui peut se faire et serra
tranchant accompagneront les critères
mais je comprends la cité nommément jean
lesbats sympa c'est que tu aurais pu
penser à nous sur le plateau c'est entre
18 et 24 licences et discriminant essayé
généralement je prends une veste mais je
vais essayer avant l'appel des verts 10
alors que signé tellier présidente du
comité miss france sylvie tellier
l'appareil ça va bien faibli ben c'est
pas alors en fait je vous appelle parce
qu'on a on a ouvert un débat dans tpm
peu ouvert à tous sur les vrais bons on
avait reçu sept est miss amandine
amandine qui était avec les tigres
avaient été sortis du concours parce
qu'elle était trop trop d'euros soit là
[Musique]
sa non sélection
je sais que l'histoire en fait nous les
élections régionales est en fait donc
elles n'étaient pas sélectionnés
d'office suite devant leurs comités qui
refait une présélection sur dossier et
l'a pas en fait à la fin a été retenu
pour cette année on a une phase
représenté l'année prochaine comme à ses
débuts alors c'est assez différent c'est
à peine s'il avait été seul avait
remporté le concours alors été chanceux
alors effectué les flics ce n'est de
faire quand vous remportez une élection
départementale
vous n'êtes pas si ce n'est de fait pour
le polar régional d'accord moi j'avais
bien précisé que comme pour les france
c'est le public un petit vote
en aucun cas c'est le comité qui
sélectionne les filles en fait c'est
juste une question est ce qui pour moi
serait pas une eau mais pourquoi vous
faites pas dans les critères de
sélection de miss france vous n'êtes pas
voilà pour être pour ce pour se
présenter il faut faire 912 rentrer dans
un taille 36 ou 38 pas plus est
clairement de dire qu' il ya des
standards de beauté à deux voies à boire
pour faire pour être dans le pourrait
depuis je conçois pas parce que ça
éviterait que certaines personnes qui
sont qui se présente et il sentiment
d'être sorti du concours parce qu'elle
rentre enfin dans un grand pas dans la
maintenance dans 1 36 voilà ce genre de
faire c'est très bien mais merci
beaucoup à tout casser il a répondu
écoutez civiles a répondu honnêtement il
savait que habito l'éducation ça passe
mieux voir